el sistema reproductor femenino incluye
la vagina
el cuello uterino
el útero
las trompas de falopio
y los ovarios
durante el sexo vaginal entre un hombre
y una mujer el semen sale del pene del
hombre y entra en la vagina de la mujer
mediante un proceso denominado
eyaculación
el semen contiene decenas de millones de
espermatozoides en la vagina los
espermatozoides pueden pasar a través
del cuello uterino del útero y de las
trompas de falopio para fertilizar un
óvulo del cuerpo de la mujer
la fertilización del lóbulo representa
el inicio del desarrollo del ser humano
una esponja anticonceptiva es un método
temporal para evitar que las mujeres
queden embarazadas También conocido como
control de natalidad o anticoncepción la
Esponja está hecha de una espuma suave
tiene una hendidura en uno de los lados
y un corto bucle de algodón adherido
evita el embarazo de dos maneras primero
la Esponja cubre el cuello uterino de la
mujer para evitar que los
espermatozoides en el semen del hombre
entren en el útero
en segundo lugar contiene una sustancia
denominada es permisiva que mata los
espermatozoides
las esponjas anticonceptivas están
ampliamente disponibles en una receta
para utilizar una esponja lávese las
manos
y retírala del paquete
mojé la completamente con agua limpia
apriete la Esponja mojada algunas veces
para activar el espermicida que se
encuentra en el interior
luego sostengala con el lado de la
hendidura orientado hacia arriba y doble
la Esponja hacia arriba
con el bucle colgando coloque la Esponja
doblada en la vagina
empújala lo más lejos que pueda dentro
de la vagina con uno o dos dedos
cuando suelte la Esponja se desplegará y
cubrirá el cuello uterino revise con el
dedo para constatar que la Esponja cubre
completamente el cuello uterino y que el
bucle cuelga en la vagina
una mujer puede tener relaciones
sexuales de inmediato o hasta 24 horas
después de la colocación de la Esponja
no deje la Esponja colocada durante más
de 30 horas
para retirarla introduzca un dedo en la
vagina para buscar el bucle de la
Esponja
enganche un dedo en el bucle y tire
lenta y suavemente
después de retirar la Esponja la basura
una esponja anticonceptiva tiene una
eficacia del 90% para evitar un embarazo
si una mujer la utiliza correctamente
todas las veces que tienes relaciones
sexuales esto significa que
aproximadamente 10 de cada 100 mujeres
quedarán embarazadas cada año las
esponjas tienen una eficacia de
alrededor de un 85%, cuando se utilizan
de forma habitual Lo que implica que
aproximadamente 15 de cada 100 mujeres
quedarán embarazadas si no las utilizan
siempre o si no las utilizan
correctamente cada vez que tienen
relaciones sexuales
el uso de la Esponja no protege a la
pareja sexual contra enfermedades de
transmisión sexual incluido el VIH